so
so
[Music]
[Music]
okay there we go what's up everyone how
is it going how are you doing
hope everyone is having a good day
because we've got
some new stuff some brand new
stuff today hyperescape you guys you
might have been hearing a little bit
about it
um i had kind of been hearing stuff
through you know rumors and stuff like
that online
so yeah it's here this is a tech test i
believe i don't think it's actually a
100 you know open data right now it's
like a closed version tech test
so we're going to hop into some games
and check it out it's going to be
interesting um i mean i hopped in one
game just to make sure the servers were
working and everything so that we didn't
have any issues when we went live
but i'm still very much fresh to this
whole
like concept of this game i'm hoping i'm
noticing here and there a little bit
of drops but yeah so the movement
before we hop in i will say the movement
is pretty good we
have sprint button obviously a slide
crouch slide
you know crouching and then sliding
feels very
like smooth there's a double jump and
there's also like a wall jump so you can
like
jump up here and then jump up here and
then jump off these things and
so i think it stresses a lot of
verticality so yeah it looks
it feels really good and what's up akash
what's up chat
i'm sorry i did not like address you
guys at first because i'm so excited
because i think this game
looks really good oh i don't know how to
turn off people's voices
ready for squad drummers only one squad
can win
by claiming and holding the crown or by
eliminating all other squads
um so yeah every now and then i feel
like
a little bit but yeah you can like
run up stuff like this run off of
everything double jump
there's gonna be some really crazy plays
in this
because i think every wall that you jump
onto you can jump off of it once so if
you jump off
this one you can jump off that and even
these little
cubes and objects in the sky anything
you can like collide with you can hop on
so this is gonna be crazy it's a very
short game that i've tried so far
oh yeah so this is like i guess your
baton or something that you start with
and then you pick up guns when you're in
the game
so yeah not that i know i don't think
there's any fall damage
on the temperatures you guys have seen
john says the music is great i do
very much enjoy the music um i don't
know where my team
is i think they're behind me so yeah
instead of dropping in
like by yourself you have this little
pod
like i said i played one game it lasted
like two minutes
because i got one kill though so that
was exciting i need to get back to the
squat
i'm playing on mousing keyboard right
now but there is controller support
yeah once you get to a certain point in
the atmosphere i guess you just
straight up drop and then you gotta go
find stuff so i
so far i don't know exactly
where things are because like you can
break this stuff right
and get in here sorry but i think only
those
these types of doors you can break
strike so they're like windows but not
windows because you can't see through
them
got these little jump pads and then
we'll double jump over there
i think i have a sniper oh i haven't
used the snipe
oh my goodness i messed up i messed up i
need to change my
i did change my sensitivity and uh i
messed something up
with the ads yeah i need to turn this up
don't mind my slow regular sensitivity
okay it's still oh i didn't hit apply
my team is done be aware of your
location contenders
sectors are starting to collapse
[Applause]
okay apply all right
okay that's a little bit better oh no
all right my team
so from what i understand
from the tutorial which i did want to
show you guys
oh goodness um was that if you find
more than one of the same gun
then it levels that gun up to be better
right so if i find two more of this
pistol i have in my hand and
or you know i'm not exactly sure how
many
levels oh you can
just go anywhere contenders
a sector has collapsed
[Applause]
[Music]
nothing has ammo oh i am in
trouble wait wait okay gearing up
oh man this is
what is kind of wanted that other gun
but it didn't have any
ammo in it i don't know confusion
okay so if your teammate dies
they can kind of follow you around like
a ghost and then if you kill
somebody you can respawn your teammates
so that person that you killed their
like death turns into like
responsibility
this guy needs to go
oh yeah so now he's a ghost and you're
always beautiful
see us he can call us out to our
teammates from
you know the ghost realm the fact that i
have to hold down the button
like for a few seconds to pick up the
gun is stressful
i already know i'm gonna get killed so
many times trying to pick up weapons
all right so what's up guys i'm uh
weapons swap is a bit slow i just think
that sniper was slow you know like
i hear somebody here's a weapon
let's head over there 20 squads still on
the board
let's uh stick with the team shall we
so i just upped my magazine size what is
this a wall
oh okay so these are the hacks i have
not
been using these oh i already have
little equipped i'm already full life so
i'm not gonna use that yet
where in the world see i'm not being
vertical enough i'm spending too much
time on the ground this is my first
mistake
the viewers have chosen the reveal event
oh that's another thing
i think i think people who are watching
can influence certain things that happen
in the game
maybe that's what that reveal thing is
talking about oh no
no i think they just found something
they found something
special
the reveal event is ending okay thank
goodness i don't feel safe
someone's trying to snipe it sectors are
about to collapse
so i don't notice a mini map on my
screen right now
i'm trying to figure out other ways to
tell if the sucker that i'm
in is gonna die
oh so that's also a purse
you can basically turn into a giant
hamster ball
oh no oh i missed the water
oh no oh yeah
oh no yo he destroyed me okay
that's fine i'm about to be a shadow
yeah okay so now i have a shadow
and now i think i can like
you can't do anything as much so if
you're like playing with a squad
oh you're a language mister
all right well that was fun even though
we're still getting
we're still getting used to it we're
still getting used to it
15th that's not bad actually i don't
know how many squads we start with
but yeah i actually really like how this
game feels so far
um this is a tech test so
it's i don't know if that means it's
technically a beta or if another beat is
going to be on the way
or if this is like you know
just to text us i guess i'm not sure so
let's hop
into another one and try to
process all the information at once
so i have to remember to use my
abilities which i used to heal when
there and it did kind of help me out
um yeah there
is a high range time to kill
by claiming so you at least if you're
so what do you guys think so far i mean
i know
this is only the first game you've seen
here on this stream and
i'm still getting used to it but oh i
should change
okay
think it's just gonna be free to play
favors
i mean that's usually the theme with
most of the new battle royale
far i like this because i like movies
you know i've been playing a lot of
ballerina which is like a 180 from this
and like so this is a nice like change
of pace
like you know jump around scale all the
buildings
[Music]
jump from the heavens with like a
machine gun
like last round it's like the same place
last time it's not intentional but at
least i know i can
go over here
always okay so i picked up a mic here we
go
i got this gun i should never we have
our first
elimination bullets for that actually
because
ammo is scarce oh
oh no
oh no oh no
oh what did i hit that brought my mouth
up
i need to be smarter all right can i
pink there's another oh i can ping
all right so you know if you wanted to
you could just follow these people
around
in the shadow room and just expose where
they are
the entire time be aware of your
patients
sectors are starting to collapse when
you guys squat up with your bros
oh oh that i get it
i get it that is smart see that's how
you lose your feet
there's an enemy i don't know if
there's a lot of people in here
there's an enemy there's an enemy
oh man they are
yeah i think
oh i think those are other
[Music]
but i do like that they let you run
around like that because
it kind of keeps players like from
quitting i guess
at least you get to feel like you're
helping a little bit
all right so that one didn't go well but
it's fine
uh next are we loading
hyper escape hub so your hub too you can
run around
and check out different things like the
news and updates you like run into this
portal and it takes you here
kinda cool
all right let's get into another one
[Music]
but yeah there is controller support by
the way
if you saw me messing with some of the
controller or the
keyboard binding series controller
options in there too
so ready for squad grand rush ps4
can win by claiming and holding the
crown or by eliminating
all other squads not sure if that's been
announced yet but they did say on
twitter that i think
that they were going to be announcing
more stuff about the game so i'm pretty
sure they're going to announce
everything
everything else that you guys want to
know like more on the technical side
instead of gameplay
so check it out if you guys want to see
it
get ready to deploy but yeah exactly
choose your drop location carefully
players
gradient concept seems confident
in this helio shop
see these other guys
you know got a bunch of people dropping
there with you i know
oh [ __ ] hey let's do it tim you want to
hit the house hit the house hit these
houses up here which ones which ones
oh no they've changed course okay here
we go
there's a few people here
anything else in here just getting
started
see i get a little strike one from the
board
[Music]
okay this looks like a speed up i can
use this
gearing up so another thing
i'm actually not sure about is hack here
block damage oh yeah always usually so
that's my
e and i have a teleport and this one is
a mine
back here which also something could be
useful because i feel like last game
our teammates got this dude right above
me
man i feel like i'm stuck on the other
side
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
um
watch out for collapsed sectors
i didn't make it out the window but it's
[ __ ] weird we all
no let me oh
[Applause]
let me go over here
[Music]
until they come and revive me
i feel like it's a vr that's insane
getting you back up offensively
oh crap it's fine it's fine don't do
what you got to do
protect yourself oh there's someone they
killed indoors maybe i should go to that
one
hey can i get around you back up he's
right there
he didn't see him okay
here we go all right cool
be careful they're both in that building
[Applause]
[Music]
a sector has collapsed
there's one more somewhere here though i
thought
yeah i could still hear his footsteps
around i'm kind of just using them
which is like a really good um
i mean i heard two man i don't know
yeah that sounds a little weird in this
game
it sounds like they're coming from
everywhere
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
with this one
[Music]
we gotta get out of here anyway dude i
can't have you activate over yeah
oh he's dead oh yeah
how do we get out of here
which way do we even go
it's pretty it's pretty fast
[Music]
i'm gonna head out of here though but
there's a dude over where i just marked
it
gotcha
i don't think there's a change in
running depending on gun
it's like right behind me
nice
man i'm gonna have like freaking every
single assist in this game
i don't mind you hey assists are good
man as long as you get them kills at the
end
i'm going to come over here okay
these guys are cool if y'all see another
uh
auto or semi-auto weapon let me know
it's about to be out of ammo
collapsing someone's definitely a
so health health auto regenerates
after a short amount of time
oh okay he's coming up the stairs he's
coming up the stairs now the level ups
in the weapons actually didn't make a
big difference i think he had still
going up
yeah yeah yeah he's born right now
oh crap
i was running up on somebody like
somebody from gamespot
was he talking about me i really was not
um
they couldn't hear me talking i don't
think
that's funny no that was fun though
that was fun i actually am enjoying this
like i'm not doing very well but i like
the concept so far
it was pretty fun all right let's try
this again
guys try this again
teamwork is key it really is i should be
talking to the teammates but
there are definitely some major
differences between this and something
like apex actually
because none of these um characters that
you're using
have abilities off the jump the
abilities are all things
more options find a loadout that you
like
yeah i mean so far from the guns i
picked up
they all look the same like in terms of
like there's one type of pistol one type
of sniper
yeah there's that big like machine gun
thing
i wish i could figure out if these like
random drops
were from the game
thank goodness there's no falling down
when they made tetris 99 i was like oh
vr is
i like the music
[Music]
okay so we got three jump pads along the
side of this building
wait i actually want to go inside
roof ooh okay this place is useful
all right so i got armor and teleport
are there any guns in here or is this
all hacks
oh okay i'll take that and i'll take
that
okay let me ping some guns for my team
or i could just be selfish
wow wait that was oh no oh no
oh no i did it again
they're everywhere
oh one on one
just kidding there's another person
if there's an enemy if there's an enemy
i will follow i will haunt you
no we didn't make it
nice try
that was fun okay so that's a hot spot i
feel like i think that
you know like with any br there's gonna
be certain areas that are gonna be super
popular
okay i can just find another match from
here sweet
oh there is a battle pass too actually
we can check that guy that out after if
he wants you guys
but yeah what is this game this is
hyperscape
right now i feel like they really want
people to be
fast they want them to have good
movement they want it you know
you have a chance to run away if someone
doesn't see you first
but on the flip side of that we saw how
much damage i took from
a fully leveled up fused you know
maximum
fused weapon i died pretty fast with
full health
so maybe the time to kill just looks
long right now because
we're all just playing it for the very
first time and
you know we haven't seen this hasn't
been broken apart by
players yet every single game that comes
out
and hits beta you guys already know what
happens
the gamers break it they find all the
glitches
and all the optimal top tier things
it happens every time don't [ __ ] that
don't head there actually i see a bunch
of things let's get back to this
let's go to uh i feel like i haven't
gone much further than this area
at all oh no
it didn't hurt me but
the kids on the train
while this throws up a massive wall i
already have that one
so hold on
real enemies
all right it's pretty quiet over here
actually we may have finally landed
somewhere
that wasn't super spicy
okay that was my teammate i gotta hear
stuff
warning sectors will soon be collapsing
wait let me go okay so tab is my map
gotcha so it's less of a ring that's
forever closing in and it's more like
sectors that start to collapse around
you
because this is all a simulation
[Music]
oh no i wanted to uh
a new hack you just hold it and then you
click left to switch out the cue or
right
to switch out the e interesting
how are you i hear
somebody is there a time limit on this
wall
someone is here
let's head over there
that was fun just a moment
all right so i think i really like the
queue just simply because you can
cover so much ground it goes super high
up in the air
all right that sector is gone should
probably move
but where to go is the question be aware
of your location contenders
sectors are starting to collapse okay
i'm trying to see which ones are
specified
there might not go on oh okay the red
ones were the ones that are about to
expire
not the ones that were already expiring
got it got
it are you fighting someone over there
hmm
my teammates seem pretty satisfied
staying over here
invisibility because temporarily watch
out for collapsed
sectors yeah let's try that out we've
tried to
although i do like the teleport one
actually but oh
you saw that weird little skit that's
been happening here and there which is
the viewers have chosen the extra jump
event
can we triple jump
the viewers have chosen it felt so like
hunger games
people are watching us
all right come on team let's be
aggressive
i'm getting bored like i don't want to
leave them behind but
sectors are about to collapse i also
want to
shoot people with this giant gun
that i have
so i'm not sure what all the the special
events are that viewers can pick but
that was the second one we've seen so
far i think
oh i was definitely triple jumping
that was fun the extra jump event is
ending
[Applause]
i'll try to get all the extra jumps i
can get in before it's too late
to get up here oh i should have started
jumping around more earlier no
all right i left my team unless there's
someone over here
i don't think so
yeah if i had an extra jump
i'm not gonna use my cue to get up there
for sure
the alert contenders a sector has
collapsed
all right which one's next
don't know yet but i hear
a lot of action in the distance i feel
like this corner is so far like we're
about to get cut off next i think
we should get out of here or maybe i'm
being paranoid i'm not exactly sure how
the sectors work yet
if it's always an outer perimeter thing
or if it's going to be
truly random warning
sectors will soon be collapsing oh yeah
see this one's gone
so we gotta go
it's kind of weird not having a minnie
mouse i need to get back to the squat
or maybe they need to get to me because
there's people over here too i saw
[Applause]
ghosts
[Music]
no i wanted to steal that
[Music]
but i'm definitely not giving up right
now
all right
ten squads still fighting for dominance
oh i wonder if this is
also so when you get them to a certain
amount of squash it's not just
low gravity oh
my goodness low gravity event huh
[Music]
[Music]
oh just kidding oh is he above me
somewhere
we're all floating
[Music]
no way watch out oh no
event is ending you can't see me
you can't see me
no
i'm reading your echo thank you
what
i'm
i gotta go i have no i have nothing
my bad teammates
hi invisibility sectors are about to
collapse
legit i just
and i'm not leveling up any of my guns
which is not a good idea
of all these level one guns wanna get
the end game everyone's gonna have
single shot energy cannon i don't think
like
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
is he shooting at someone or was someone
shooting at him
can't tell it got really quiet like
there's no more
game music ambient noise
i don't know a sector has collapsed
i feel like for this game there's no
reason to not be on the roof right
the viewers have chosen the reveal event
okay
so they see us we should be able to see
them right
[ __ ] i've been revealed centers will
soon be collapsing
[Music]
the reveal event is ending i was short
i feel like i don't see anybody though
is it an event just for the person who
activated it
i don't know
five squads are still standing we're in
the top five though let's go
five squads still in play
only five squads remain is the crown
available now how many squads does there
have to be for the crown to be available
or is that a different mode
um where are they at hold on let me look
at this
all right so the mat is getting pretty
small like
for five squads we should see a sector
has collapsed
this map is so dense too it's gonna be
really
what's up y'all what's up y'all and you
[Applause]
sectors are about to collapse you
[Applause]
[Music]
final four oh
[Music]
[Applause]
i see enemies on low ground just pass by
the tunnel
oh
no he killed me in the air i honestly
didn't know if i could be killed out of
the air like that
but watch out for people it was a good
run
[Applause]
[Music]
contenders sectors are starting to
collapse
we're down to three squads plans
no phoenix
all right good
three two one oh jam had four kills the
jam was going off
god i suck at this we'll do the skin
spin out literally for one
hour it's fine all right
let's keep it going what do you guys
think so far
i mean totally fair to have honest
opinions
everyone has their own preference
i feel like i'm enjoying it so far but
yeah i'm not very good at it either
the only thing i know for sure that i
like is like the
that hack where i could just jump in the
air and ground pound everybody
so you know the invisibility one's
pretty good too
i'm trying to think which other ones did
i use so far welcome contenders
today you and your friends against all
other squads if mixed i feel like maybe
the teleport one or something or
probably that groundhog one i was
leaving so that you can activate both
and not have them shoot you out of the
air
you might play if they introduce rings i
mean
i feel like every single beerus has
oh i'm feeling so many
skips now it's slowly starting to get
more
skinny i don't know if it's because
everyone's right here running around
and being crazy that's anything i'm not
using enough as a slide
yeah i think it's probably worth at
least trying out
i didn't get to play any of this
all right take i don't know five six how
many games played so far
that was definitely the longest lasting
one and we were in top nine
yeah i don't think i see anybody else
i feel like the cool thing about if you
don't like
games you don't have to play it
that's the cool thing about so many
games being available
like if this one's not happening then i
guarantee you
eventually there's one down or one
that's already out that you like
there's something for everyone all right
so we got the arms i can use this
here we go
well i really don't have a lot of
interest in
just getting started
i need to get back to the squad just a
moment
now that's a fact oh okay
so those boxes give you super special
stuff
nice like no wonder that guy already had
like a fully maxed out
something the other game that we play be
aware of your location contenders
sectors are starting to collapse ahead
of you i'll leave that one
oh i hear a lot of people in here
so i am not
but i found a fully maxed up hack so
it wasn't totally useless hopefully
they're not chasing me
in here
i want that why wouldn't that
stop stop it here we go
cheering is caring oops that was nice
sharing is caring
maybe i shot this instead the pistol
just getting started
all right the viewers have chosen the
extra jumping
ooh okay now that i know that
i hear someone let's head over there
watch out
they see me oh my game is skipping more
and more
i don't know i already turned the
graphics down
too from 100.
[Applause]
[Music]
morning
[Applause]
the extra jump event oh i forgot extra
jump event was going see how fast it is
[Applause]
always useful where'd they go
20 squads still on the board
[Applause]
about to die where are we going oh
my goodness we've definitely
gotta go contenders a sector has
collapsed
we're gonna take damage
[Music]
oh
i feel like there's just so much in here
right now that my brain is
slowly starting to collapse information
like how many packs you can add two and
you can switch them out you can level up
your gun and there's events and there's
players choice stuff and
when you're dead people can follow you
there's a lot going on
and the sectors close up pretty fast but
honestly i think
i don't mind that because you know
even when i first started playing battle
royale games
i had a big issue with how slow i
thought it felt
um before i really just started getting
used to battle royale so this is a nice
change of piece for me
[Applause]
even though we haven't run into anybody
yet
[Applause]
you would just like fall off the map
instantly like watch that in the ring
which i'd be down for that too to be
honest
it takes a while before the sector's
fully closed
all right on made it y'all then get some
really weird the viewers have chosen the
reveal event
it's like starting to get worse oh i
didn't want to do that
is
oh
oh
oh the tree the tree was too powerful
holding somebody
you made it away
we're down
sectors are starting to collapse
are all of our teammates okay
i was like oh man
that was actually pretty fun the ar
is definitely my preference so far
but that level four shotgun holy crap
like two shots and
i was gone all right so i wanted to show
you guys
some of the other stuff in the hub real
quick
for those of you interested for you
people who like the battle pass
things in games honestly the only games
i've ever gotten a battle pass for it
was
apex and valerian so this is the battle
pass ooh
i'm almost to the next level so i really
don't know what's in here yet because i
haven't looked it's like
different kinds of pods
jet set rare pod
emblems the crown
hollow tag i guess these are sprays
celebration poses
skins
oh okay they do have character skins too
that's cool
i wasn't sure if they were or not but i
mean obviously it's battle pass
oh there's only ten levels okay okay i
i don't know why i was expecting like a
hundred levels but
it's like the game's not even out yet
why would there be a hundred thousand
oh yeah so let's play um
probably maybe like one or two more
before we gotta wrap
up for the day but yeah thanks for
hanging out
and joining us ar damages though yeah i
definitely had to use like an entire
clip
had i been
without a mini map now i don't know if i
accidentally turned off my mini map or
something
but but yeah
so i'm constantly like trying to look
here to look
to see where i'm supposed to go i'm
already like
really bad with directions in real life
maybe a mini map on the upper left
the team bars on the bottom left could
be like a little bit
smaller so just so it wouldn't feel so
cluttered
man i am really i feel like maybe it's
my computer
i don't know i don't see any drops in
the actual stream itself
sound quality there's there's a sound
quality
the hell is this ambient
um this is not available on steam right
now this is just
a text test kind of like really choice
um but at 11 00 pacific time 11 a.m
time they did announce on twitter that
they were going to be
i guess giving more information about
the game
so stay tuned for that after this stream
oh where my family is going
all right let's get inside a building
get some
loots oh the shotgun
just getting started always useful
okay now my goal should be
to find more of these same weapons
level one okay
[Applause]
there is definitely some action
there's a lot of people over here is
that a ghost oh no that's a real person
be aware of your location contenders
sectors are starting to collapse
oh reloading takes 10 years i need to
get back to the spot
i'm going to be rethinking
all of my ammo i'm not killing anybody
nice way to go
me oh i got two assists all right all
right i don't feel so bad
i think i got two or at least got one
[Applause]
man my team's over there when they could
be a part of all this action
oh someone's not even here i'll take the
free kill on the board
on the board yeah totally earned it
i feel like there's no reason why i
shouldn't be on top of a roof
[Applause]
i'm getting a lot of skin watch out for
collapsed
sectors
i'm just trying not to fall off of this
the second i fell it was all downhill
from there
wait did my teammate join me in the
shadow round
[Music]
no sectors are about to collapse
we failed you wait someone's still alive
oh wait there you go
[Applause]
wow what happened or did he just take
the jump pad
20 squats nice tracking
so what nice
yes we were indeed eliminated the whole
team was dead
hmm i might be able to get to tier 2
today
possibly we'll see
oh that's interesting kevo says i don't
mind to be here again from ub but they
should have made it based on one of
their ip universes which one would you
like to see
like which one that they already have
could you see as a br that would
make the most sense we're playing squad
crown rush
prepare yourselves and plan to deal with
all the other sports this really doesn't
feel like a uv game yeah it really
doesn't
defenders
i mean there's something to be said for
that too
stepping outside of their box their
comfort zones
and look at that this is kind of cool
actually
overlook the whole [ __ ] [ __ ]
these gamers and their language i'm just
kidding
you guys have heard me first before
just like foggy polluted city
it's a pretty big map though looking
around settings
and then your keyboard options and then
customize controls
after the stream is done i definitely
want to like restart this game and see
if it runs
smoothly to see
if it's just my computer or
like over time
me personally i like jumping around and
doing all kinds of crazy stuff
um player so that's a given
so games like this it doesn't take much
for me to like the game in all honesty
that's why i don't do reviews because i
like everything
you see how some of the map is grayed
out and stuff
because not 33 people are in here so the
less amount of people it goes off of how
many people are in here interesting
nice thank you uh teammate
for dropping some i mean i don't know
either but
yeah i do feel like that area is gone i
need to get back to the squat
i am i'm going oh it's really far
oh no
please let me get at least close enough
okay
one down already i didn't even touch the
ground yet
okay
[Music]
oh this guy's breathing in his mind
i can use this
it's centered in your
warning sectors will soon be collapsing
that was so weird that they censored
that
but i don't think you saw my message
anyways
can i mute
maybe not
[Music]
so which sector are we in
yeah i don't know i was like did i
misspell
[Music]
let me at least try to get
oh yeah always useful
gearing up
the viewers have chosen the infinite
that's a dope event
where the enemy's at a machine gun that
means there's a streamer here
oh yeah well i'm sure there is i've seen
some people and somebody
donated them to get that
sectors are about to collapse
[Music]
so interesting so someone has to donate
to a streamer for them to do those
events that is
interesting it really is like the hunger
games
holy [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
voting
they're so low
over here no oh get me right here
i'm right here
yeah come on
[ __ ] it's
[Music]
he alright he's so sneaky
i thought we had him all right well is
there a response
yeah someone else
still fighting
hey can i get a rest
did i just do it now you got to hold
this
on your echo raising your echo
the viewers have chosen the low gravity
can i get around
oh no
are we in anti-gravity
now my gun's golden
reloading five
yeah the golden guns pretty good
i want to switch out this mine
oh no
don't worry guys i'll be right there i
know
a single shot sniper don't mind if i
do what else
warning watch out for collapsed
defectors
oh i missed the wall jump
i should communicate with my teammates i
mean i should you're right oh no oh no
someone's here
oh i see him over here i try to get away
he killed me really fast time to kill
wasn't so bad
there's an enemy warning sectors will
soon be collapsing
there's an enemy
oh they're all down here
oh no he didn't make it
darren
got the canon and he has cute or
not cute i only called it that's where i
have it but here's the little
ground pound thing
oh nice oh five squads remain oh we
almost
have to top five again
all right nice try nice try
all right i think one more
and then we have to wrap but
um yeah
okay just checking our time yeah one
more and then we're gonna be
wrapping it up i hope you guys are
enjoying this so far
for those of you who feel like this
style of shooters
prepare yourselves
but yeah you know hour one day one
not bad i would say the biggest issues
i'm having is
i guess over time the game is getting a
little
more choppy like you stephen right now
but i don't know if that just said we
got
literally like 30 people jumping around
at the same time in here
not sure the first like game or two
there was no issue at all
yeah this is a tech demo
how can you talk when you're a structure
thing oh so
i can still ping and stuff
i can still ping and stuff when i'm uh
when i'm in the afterlife
i don't remember what exactly was
followed
but i still ping and run around and
they could possibly revise me
like i know i haven't been communicating
with my teammates but when you do have a
squad it's probably going to be really
important
for people to use their shadows for
recon
just getting started strike one from the
board
always useful
[Applause]
here we go i need to get back to it
i wonder how fast the teleport cooldown
is when it's on level five
[Applause]
it's like seven seconds sectors are
about to collapse
[Applause]
make
yeah
[Applause]
explosive check
but
there's just so many places you could go
to it feels like what's in here
oh heck yeah
it's mine
warning watch out for collapsed sectors
i saw someone over there glitching
around
oh
i still need to fix my ads speed
cause it's wrong all right so these are
not
very good
together
[Music]
oh
will soon be collapsing
um i feel like it's one of those last
resorts
like i need to just save it for a rainy
day
[Music]
[Applause]
oh that guy's definitely
[Applause]
oh
okay i'm at least taking that ride
i mean that's definitely some
winston-style tactics right there not
gonna lie
so far all the kills i've gotten in this
game were from me doing that ground
pound
into the machine gun
um but yeah you guys hyper escape
it is on the way and very soon in like
15 minutes actually
they're gonna be doing an announcement
of sorts i believe i saw that was the
time
on twitter uh so yeah stay tuned for
that thank you so much for joining
us and more on hyperescape to come not
only
in general but right here on gamespot so
thank you guys so much for tuning in and
i will see you later peace out
you